نحو سبعه ملايين سياره هو مجموع المركبات
المسجله في الجزائر قد يبدو الرقم كبيرا
لكن مع ذلك يعاني السوق من عجز كبير وهذا
بعدما تهاول استيراد في السنوات الثمان
الماضيه منحو 95% وتوقف الانتاج المحلي ما
رفع اسعار السيارات الى مستويات قياسيه
قرار الحكومه الذي يسمح باستيراد السيارات
المستعمله لاقل من ثلاث سنوات اصاب السوق
بالشلل انتظارا لبدء اجراءات الاستراد
مطلع العام المقبل
[تصفيق]
حابس حاليا حابس الناس خائفه همم خائفه
تشرين وكان للناس خائفه تبيع
فسوقوا السيارات في الجزائر الغارقه في
القدم بحاجه الى نحو مليوني سياره قبل
تحقيق توازن بين العرض والطلب
500,000 سياره هذا طالب ااه موجود الى حد
الان وذلك الانقطاع منذ حوالي اربعه سنوات
تكاد ذلك الطلب يعني ربما هو اكثر من 500
الف سياره حاليا
امام فقدان سوق السيارات لتوازنها تشكل
العوده الى بعث نشاط التركيب محليا احد
الحلول بعد انتهاء عمليه تحويل املاك
المصانع المصادره من ملاكها المتهمين
بالفساد الى حيازه القطاع العام
اربعه 10 شركه مصادره باحكام قضائيه باتت
معنيه باستعاده نشاطها توازيا مع عقود مع
مجمعات عالميه لصناعه السيارات واولها فئه
ايطاليه
بالشروط الجديده بتاع الشروط الجزائريه كل
هذا وجه الهدف انتهى والهدف التعاون اسس
الى صناعه ميكانيكيه حقيقيه همم مواجهه
الاستهلاك الداخلي وكذلك مجال استخدام في
انتظار نتائج التوجهات الحكوميه الجديده
يترقب الجزائريون مدى تاثيرها على الاسعار
بعد وقف الاستراد لسنوات طويله
الجزيره الجزائر